moi c'est clio sont évidemment à 20 ans
vous rigolez moi c'est vous ça n est
même pas rachat de sas et mercedes avec
l animateur aimeriez vous passer la nuit
vous matthieu delormeau vous avez choisi
qui s'est choisi au pas il a perdu une
dent dans le kent alors oui alors gens
comme moi j'ai choisi ophélie meunier aa
du tube du tube est bas alors il n'a pas
choisi la plus moche non non non
j'aimerais bien découvrir
je peux vous dire que franchement je
trouve que c'est la fille la plus jolie
actuellement à la télévision mais c'est
une bombe
total est franchement si ça l'amusé je
ne serait ce qu'une fois mais je
reconnais que coucher avec quelque chose
qui me bat base est passé une nuit c'est
pour faire comme si je peux me permettre
je ne vous comprends plus non mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ophélie meunier vous êtes d'accord jean
michel mr a oui si on a un gros tube
génère days elle est un peu froide
je pense qu'effectivement il faut la
modeler un peu discuté avec l entrée
dans sa tête pour comprendre qui elle
est vraiment ça mon avis là là vous lui
faites ça l'a appelé la police depuis
cinq minutes de la fin le 17 la meuf la
wiimote et les meuniers is a way les
super mignonne mais elle est pas très
froides ne s'est pas vraiment eu à
croiser les froides à l'extérieur les
chats d'ailleurs la gare
[Rires]
clio alors on attend là à aller dit guy
lagache
mais dans la chaîne mais oui c'est pas
parce qu'il est dans la chaîne chercher
c'est la mèche blonde c'est ce côté
premier de la classe qui je pense est
très sauvage en réalité alors quand je
les ai vus
sachez le il est sauvage voilà non c'est
à dire qu'il n'est pas dupe et l'autre
je me dis que j'ai vu un jour la vie de
la mère il n'est pas dans les locaux de
la savane allemand il agira mais tous
n'ont pas une femme et tout le monde a
une femme fort et eric sa caisse calais
non mais ça va arrêter d'être 2015 sans
décoller vivez avec votre canon on peut
pas dire contrôle ça veut dire guy
lagache vient vous voir dans les
couloirs de 10,8 et vous dis je vous
emmène en week end
voilà même à rungis vous y allez moment
je vais cueillir des fraises avec lui
mais enfin oui oui pourquoi pas oui mais
non mais moi aussi j'ai quelqu'un mais
je devais répondre alors j'ai répondu
alors mail alors alors je vous dire ici
ah mais oui ici quand on est dans cette
émission
plus personne à personne il faut partir
mais nous aussi les autres personnes
michel mr eux je les adore les tonneaux
mais qu'est-ce que je me fous de votre
avis sur guy lagache bien sûr on est
tous et non on va pas on lance tout de
suite asta gros loulou ses clio sont
évidemment à 20 ans vous rigolez moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous ça elles mêmes par chaque sas
et mercedes gilles verdez sophie davant
ah ah oui ça sent bien la davar oui à
deux cérébraux correctement la peur en
tunisie sophie davant oui sophy diarra
sera ça veut dire il ya très longtemps
là il ya deux personnes qu'on puisse
être admises ou qui fait je pense qu'on
aurait des choses à se dire au bout de
la nuit et brouillard sur la photo quand
même un petit peu oui oui oui mais bon
non mais c'est quelqu'un de très bien et
je pense que voilà on pourrait se
raconter des histoires allaient l'un
vers l'autre frère un papa forcément se
toucher tout de suite je pense que les
blues d'un certain temps quoi voilà on
est deux aides qui finalement ça tire
après des débuts difficiles
d'accord on va ne l'aiment pas le sexe
qua non [ __ ] qu'une nuit un bout
sophie davant way ah non pas trop non
n'en reste pas trop drôle moi alors mon
choix si valérie la meinau mais par
contre il faudrait pas qu'on soit sur un
lit superposé balle eric j'adorerais il
sauverait la une sao elle va dormir en
ra sera toute la nuit et madonna comme
ça non mais je la maroufle et des images
d'une je comprends mais elle est sexy
elle est sexy valérie je suis d'accord
je suis d'accord jean-luc guilaine chenu
et françoise joly sur des pressions
envoyé spécial parce que je pense que
son besoin de réconfort en ce moment
l'armée dans la mission s'arrête et je
pense qu'ils ont du temps et puis deux
c6 bien comme celle à d'autres commerces
mission s'arrête vous auriez dû prendre
julien lepers suis pas pourquoi je
sortais mois
[Musique]